a man who says he was chow's roommate
says he was awakened by law enforcement
in the overnight hours yesterday they
had a search warrant he says the mass
shooting really comes as a shock but
says it is believable that hate was his
motivation joe moeller spoke to him and
he joins us now with what he had to say
jordan davis says he was surprised when
police showed up to his home in the
middle of the night looking for
information about david chow he says he
never expected chow could do something
like this they came to my house
unexpectedly at one o'clock in the
morning jordan davis shared this video
of chow's room after it was searched i
can't believe that i was basically
living with a mass killer at this point
a mass shooter a previous neighbor of
chow said he left this apartment in
february and that is when davis says he
moved into the house to put it simply he
was a very kind generous guy he treated
me and my dog very accordingly
he also identified himself as a
christian much like i do authorities
believe chow was targeting the taiwanese
community when he opened fire inside the
church he told me though that hey he
wants absolutely nothing to do with
taiwan authorities say chow is
originally from china and has lived in
the united states for several years his
ex-wife moved to taiwan recently davis
says he did mention dislike for taiwan
in the past and believes that could be
the motive as well i would have to say
it probably is the case especially when
he was telling me that he had also left
taiwan
because of how he just wasn't liking how
things were rolling there politically
authorities say chow did not have any
ties to the church where the shooting
happened davis questions how someone who
claimed to be a religious person could
be so violent now i just think that this
is just going to be what just one of
those
very bad memories that's just going to
always be a part of my life davis says
he did not know chow had firearms in the
home he says he was a security card at
multiple locations including some areas
around the strip reporting in spring
valley joe muller live local now